هذا واعرب البيت الابيض عن قلقه البالغ
ازاء اعمال العنف في المسجد الاقصى وحتى
جميع الاطراف على تجنب المزيد من التصعيد
وقالت للمتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض
انه من الضروري الان اكثر من اي وقت مضى
خفض التصعيد بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيلي
فيما يتعلق بما شهدناه مؤخرا في المسجد
فنحن ما زلنا قلقين للغايه من استمرار
العنف ونحث جميع الاطراف على تجنب المزيد
من التصعيد من الضروري الان اكثر من اي
وقت مضى ان يعمل الاسرائيليون
والفلسطينيون معا لخفض التوترات واستعاده
الهدوء وكما تعلمون هذا ما يقوله الرئيس
والاداره سرا وعلانيه طوال الاسابيع السته
الماضيه وستستمر بدعوتنا هذه
استياءه مما يحدث في الاقصى وطالب بالحفاظ
على الوضع القانوني القائم للاماكن
المقدسه في مدينه القدس
نتابع الوضع الحالي في اسرائيل والاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله الاتحاد الاوروبي يشعر
بقلق عميق من تصاعد التوتر والعنف خلال
ساعات الماضيه في باحث الاقصى وفي الوقت
نفسه ندين بشده الهجمات الصاروخيه من قطاع
غزه باتجاه اسرائيل من المهم للغايه في
هذا الوقت ان نحافظ على الوضع القانوني
القائم وندعو جميع الاطراف الى ضبط النفس
والعمل على خفض حده التوتر الحاصل واحترام
ما يتعلق بشعائر الدينيه
ومن جهتها حثة الخرجه الصينيه اسرائيل على
التزام الهدوء وضبط النفس والوقف الفوري
لاي افعال تزيد من حده الصراع وقالت
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الصينيه ان وضع
القدس معقد وحساس وان على جميع الاطراف ان
تحافظ على الوضع التاريخي للاماكن المقدسه
اتخاذ تدابير جوهريه لتعزيز تنفيذ حل
الدولتين